bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à l'heure la justice qui
demande donc l'arrestation de rafael
correa est ce que c'est possible à ce
que des accords d'extradition par
exemple existent entre la belgique et
l'équateur bonjour alors je pense qu'il
est important de signaler qui s'assied
qu'il s'agit quand même d'un process
essentiellement politique enrobés dans
des accusations de corruption ren très
douteuses qui ont deux objectifs
fondamentaux on pourra en reparler mais
éviter que monsieur coréens sont
physiquement en équateur mais aussi
éviter que correa soit candidat à la
présidence qui est la préoccupation
majeure administration moreno donc c'est
un procès essentiellement politique je
pense basé sur des accusations très
douteuse et jusqu'à présent toutes les
demandes équatorienne d'arrestation donc
à travers d'interpol qui est
l'organisation internationale qui doit
émettre ces notices rouges pour que les
personnes qui sont en dehors du
territoire des pays où ils sont
recherchés soit arrêté jusqu'à présent
toutes ces demandes équatorienne
d'arrestations ont été signés par
l'interpol qui a refusé de d'activer
l'alerté rouge justement parce que
l'interpol a considéré qu'il s'agissait
d'un procès essentiellement politique et
interpol ne veut pas participer dix ans
d'une poursuite politique persécutions
politiques de cette nature contre
monsieur correia donc je pense nous
allons voir ce qu'il se produit mais je
pense qu'il est très peu probable que
interpol demandera à belgique de
d'arrêter monsieur correia de leur
envoyant des facteurs je pense que c'est
une hypothèse assez peu probable
concrètement quelle est la teneur de ces
condamnations que reproche la justice
équatorienne à l'ancien président rafael
correa
alors l'accusation en elle-même ce sont
des pots-de-vin qu'une ancienne
conseillère de monsieur coréades y avoir
reçu en sa connaissance
mais enfin il faut quand même dire que
la preuve maîtresse est un cahier un le
cahier de cette conseillère très
important de comprendre que ce cas y est
écrit au présent ou passé composé de
l'indicatif si vous voulez
donc des zones at la notation du type
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu tant d'argent de
telles personnes
le problème c'est qui s'est révélée
après que ce cahier avaient été imprimés
quatre ans après les faits que la
conseillère décrit dans son cahier donc
l'effet qu'elle décrit ce sont déroulés
en 2013 et en 2014
mais elle écrit que j'insiste 1
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu tant d'argent dans
un casier qui était physiquement imprimé
en 2018 donc elle était obligée de
changer sa version est de dire que l
avez écrit ce ce cahier enfin les notes
de ce cahier de mémoire donc c'est un
procès qui était évidemment accusés
d'être des traces et scandaleux d'être
truquée par bon nombre de personnes pas
seulement des personnes favorables à
aura l'ancien président correa il faut
aussi dire que la justice équatorienne
depuis 2018 a été complètement intervenu
un par l'administration moreno c'est une
justice en autonomie
moreno en 2008 10 2018 a rempli le
système judiciaire grandi choristes
convaincu dans toutes les fonctions
n'est pas pour pouvoir percer culte et
son prédécesseur c'est une des raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle je vois peu
probable une arrestation de monsieur
prix en belgique où une demande enfin
une activation de notices rouges
d'interpol parce que vraiment il ya des
problèmes très graves avec le procès en
lui-même
l'autonomie de la justice l'autonomie
des juges c'est un cetain c'est un
procès politique c'est évident pour
éviter que monsieur pour air qui
gagnerait les élections en février
puisse être candidat sur le binôme donc
il serait pas candidat à la présidence
parce que monsieur moreno a déjà changé
la constitution donc il peut plus être
candidat à la présidence mais il
pourrait être candidat à la
vice-présidence ce qui donnerait
énormément de force au binôme correista
août binôme qui est à la quête de faire
la tête du kit elle se trouve
aujourd'hui le candidat en délaisse
alors monsieur donc merci et d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt franc je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères en équateur
analystes au cep air centre d'études en
recherche politique économique merci
d'avoir été avec